- I'm a little bit nervous
about exposing this secret
and I also don't want to,
like, break his heart.
We're here so I can tell my dad
a secret that I've been keeping
for, like, 16 years.
- I'm nervous.
I don't know what kind of secret
she could have since she's four.
- I'm really not that nervous.
I don't think he's going to be that mad.
Sometimes I makes more
sense not to say something
if it means you're not
going to get in trouble.
- I guess I'm excited to
learn about the secret.
I can't imagine he'd have
anything to hide from me.
- So, Dad.
- Nicole.
- What's the one thing that we
used to do together when I was a child?
Do you remember when you'd ask me,
"Oh, do you want to play
tennis or golf today?"
- Yes.
- My answer 100% of the
time would've been tennis
because I really, really don't like golf.
And I never liked playing
it and I just went
because I wanted to have
something to do with you
that want me beating you at tennis.
And I also think that
watching golf is really boring
and I don't understand why you watch it.
- About two months ago I
got those parking tickets
and you gave me the money and
a normal person would've mailed it in.
And then you called me
one day and were like,
"You never paid the tickets."
- Yeah.
- "I had to pay the late fee and
it was about double what the ticket was."
And I told you that, "It's
just the city's fault."
I was like, "I paid the tickets,"
kept the money, and I spent it.
- But what did you do with the money?
- 7-11 ...
- $400 on Slurpees ...
- You do what you gotta do.
- Whoa, like a weight's been lifted
off my shoulders now that you know
and I'm probably not going to watch golf
with you ever again.
- That's fine.
- [Interviewer] So, Steven,
how surprised were you?
- It got to a point
where is became obvious
that she wasn't that interested in it.
- It's not that big of a deal.
- There were late fees.
You could've just paid the ticket.
You would put the ticket
on my credit card anyway.
- I could've put it on the
credit card and kept the money.
That probably would've been smarter.
- Why would that be hard for you?
- I don't know.
Because you love it.
- That doesn't break my heart ...
Actually heartwarming
because at that young age,
at four years old, you would do something
that you didn't really like doing
because you wanted to spend time together.
- I'm the greatest.
- Now I feel like there's
probably more things
that you should be telling me.
- Well ...
- As opposed to that ...
- No, that's about as bad as it gets.
- See, I thought you would be like,
"Oh, really?" I kind of
expected you to feel cheated
out of a daughter who liked golf.
- Well, we can do that another way.
- Okay. Cool.
- [Interviewer] And how do you feel now
that you exposed your
supposedly worst secret?
- I feel about the same.
- I still like spending
time with you, though.
- I mean, you just got another
parking ticket last month.
Did you pay it?
- Yeah, I paid it.
- Uh huh ...
- There are other secrets
that you don't know about.
- Oh, really?
- I should actually pay you
when you pay the ticket on time.
- So if I paid the ticket on time
you'd give me double the money?
- I'll give you half of the late fee.
- This looks like it
worked out better for me
that I told him the secret.